so today we're working with a 1975
Ludwig Payne mobile F we're going to
clean the carburetor which will fix nine
percent of all the problems with your
vintage bike if you get a vintage bike
like this more than likely you know it's
got old gas in it or debris x' or rust
and that accumulates in it and will work
its way through your fuel system to your
carburetor alright so this is the gas
tank on this motor became this is the
fuel petcock here it regulates the fuel
from the gas tank to the carburetor you
need to make sure that's turned off
before you start cleaning this you're
going to have gas all over so turn the
fuel petcock this is the off position on
this one but it varies on each bike and
they should be marked if they're not you
can always tell by pulling the fuel
petcock off and then you know no gas
comes out so it's off the carburetors
held on to the motor by the manifold and
the simple bolt clamps the carburetor to
the manifold so we loosen that we reach
in and we wiggle it back the float bowls
held on with two little screws this is
your float bowl here this is where all
the fuel that comes down through the
carburetor settles in keep it upright
like this so in if there is any fuel in
the flow bowl it won't spill all over
and you also want to inspect that to see
if there's any rust or water or anything
in there so that's the float Bowl and if
you look inside there you can see
there's little particles of rust and
dirt so set that aside then the most
important part of clean the carburetor
is this right here this is your main jet
all the gas that comes through your gas
tank and through your fuel line and out
the bowl all go through this jet this
basically specifies how much gas gets
mixed with the air and make sure your
bike runs perfectly loosen that
and if you look very closely there is a
hole in the very center and that is what
gets clogged and that's what makes your
bike not run so to clean it sounds
pretty gross but it's fairly safe wipe
it down so it's nice and clean and then
you just blow through it so that's all
set
gotta put that back in carburetor
tighten that up and then the old gas
like look at it make sure there's no
water or anything and dump that out in a
little container just wipe it out just
again to make sure that it's nice and
clean and then you just reverse what
you've already done make sure it's nice
and tight so that it doesn't leak it on
and wheel it back in there tighten it
back up to the manifold just reattach
the fuel line and you have successfully
cleaned your carburetor
you